hello Gary thank you so much for joining
me today when you decided to retire in
2005 many thoughts you wouldn't be back
at the board would you do the same thing
all over again if you had to
absolutely I think the decision to
retire was very Timely
because for me playing chess was not
just about winning but also making a
difference
and by 2005 I realized that you know not
that I've exhausted my creative
potential but it didn't bring me the
same pleasure of
revealing new secrets of the game of
chess and I also wanted to apply my
experience my talents my skills to do
things that I believe were important so
that's why it was a you know to be it
was a very natural shift and the 2005
was an important year also a marriage so
uh Mary darsha and you know it's a it's
a almost two decades now we have kids we
build a new life so it was just the
beginning of new life
and looking back I think that was one of
the most important and timely and the
wealth of decisions I made though many
thought at the time that it was a very
spontaneous but again I I knew it was
the right moment and now nearly 20 years
later I know that that was a very very
good move that I've made how do you deal
with with the stress levels with how
much you want to win when you came back
in 2017 was one thing how do you feel
about playing now in this event oh it's
very very different because I'm an
amateur now so I'm no longer playing
chess as a professional I enjoy it
immensely because
I could have taken Gary also out of
Chess but I I had no chance of taking
chess out of Gary so it's still part of
my life part of my nature and and this
passion doesn't die so that's why I'm
always
very curious about you know Adventure
the chess board though I I recognize my
shortcomings I'm 60 my concentration is
nearly not the same as it used to be and
many games that I played lately they
were marked by blunders and mistakes
that they were not made 20 years ago but
yeah I enjoy it and I understand you
know many people also happy to see me at
the chess board though you know I'm sure
this is some sort of a Pity because I
you know I I miss many opportunities and
my performance is it's not it's not even
close to what people expected but I
I think it's it's always good to to
um uh challenge your um your skills uh
again recognizing that uh
you're not going to be on top and uh uh
I'm accomplish and lose every year to
[Music]
say
to move the pieces because I can hardly
call it playing chess because playing
chess means you would be fully you know
just engaged in every loss when I play
chess professionally was nearly
physical pain now yeah I lose very often
but yet I just I'm happy to continue
playing
this year I I have a very modest goal
just to improve my lousy performance
last year you've played really well I
believe two two years ago you've done
two years ago I did well yes you're
right so that's why again it says this
is I don't think I can I can repeat it
but let's say you know just anything in
between you know the two years
performance last year's performance
would be a good good result for someone
who hasn't touched the chess piece
physically I played a lot on the
internet that hasn't touched the chess
piece physically for a year so you
haven't done as much to prepare for this
event or you have played online no I
play online just to have friends so that
again I just did a little bit
preparation but but no matter how much
you you you you much time you spend
preparing for it it's still about your
concentration and trust me you know this
tournament it's it's for me it's a kind
of entertainment but my head is
overloaded now with much more important
priorities so that's why even if I try
to separate myself for a day or two or
three from other things uh the ongoing
war and all events that related to this
tragic
tragedy uh
it's impossible to control your
subconscious so and then and that's what
I discovered I remember back in 2017
when I just pretended I could play you
know just uh
um semi-professionally
there were moments where just you know
my conservation elapsed completely so
there were a few games I remember with
with nepo and one was with Navara or
just you know I just just for they were
blank spots and
this again no matter what I what I do I
understand it's it's inevitable because
your mind is is working uh on its own
schedule
when when you were training was there
something uh in particular that you were
doing to improve your is there a
particular exercise that people can use
to improve their visualization skills
look I I never
he never needed you know any special
exercise to improve my concentration or
or or or visual memory so it was I would
say perfect but it was
almost there and uh
um I'm afraid that the
the idea that you can share some tips
it's might be counterproductive because
yes there's some general advices you can
you you can receive but
speaking about professionals uh trying
to to improve their games you need to
actually look at this person's eyes and
also at the games and to understand
exactly what is needed and and very
often you know the the advice that you
can give to to a rising star it's very
different depending on his or her uh
playing style
that's that's very true sometimes you
want to give general advice to people
but general advice is is good but it is
but it's for the beginners you know
that's why you can have a book you know
this up to a certain level general
advice works but if you want to be to be
really good so you have to uh understand
who you are you understand you look deep
deep inside and to recognize what is
your strengths what are your weaknesses
and how to deal with that and it's it's
Unique it's the decision-making process
is as unique as your DNA of fingerprints
so that's why trying to
generalize it it's it's typically it's
counterproductive a final question for
you Gary
you are going to face a lot of the
strongest chess players in America is
there someone in particular you would
you are looking forward to to play
against
I'm here already know just to to to
enjoy myself and uh I think it's it's
probably you know it's worth mentioning
that uh there are several players here
you know who are students of course such
as foundation so and uh and uh so I
really played once with Sam shanghorn
but now I have Robson uh uh Jeffrey uh
um and Sam so um first time I'll play
them look again
I'm happy there's a chance for for uh me
to play with them I'm sure they will be
very keen to play and to beat me so
maybe they can do that and so it's uh
you know somehow it's very odd feeling
because when I played professionally so
every game I played I wanted to win and
I believe I was a favorite now I know in
every game I know Underdog this is
something new to learn less pressure
I'm really looking forward to seeing you
play back at the board and wish you good
luck thank you very much thank you
thank you